if you think back in history there are
themes of continuity and change there
are themes of of country versus city
there are themes of Tolerance versus
intolerance there are themes of progress
versus anti-progress or you know the
opponents of privacy I don't just mean
status quo powers but I also mean anti
intellectuals and non intellectuals
people just you know primitive ests
people who who you know the taliban and
i think that there's a constant play
between those forces sort of a
historical Bible for me are they the
fennel adele's large three-volume
history of capitalism and there's an
observation that he makes in there that
it's a large generalization but it's but
it's largely true that before the
Industrial Revolution there really was
not much economic growth I mean the
economic growth was per capita growth if
populations went up growth you know
economic activity went up if there was a
plague or war in populations declined it
went went down and there really wasn't
you know there was a little bit of
progress but yields per acre went up a
little bit but it was really slow and
then something happened with
industrialization and and output per
capita started going up and real
progress started happening we've reached
a point and that has been a profound
change in the world you know so much of
the world that we know would or so much
of the world in our heads that we know
would be recognizable to a Shakespeare
or a Thomas Jefferson but so much of the
world that we live in and walk in and
bicycle in and I
I mean a bicycle would be
incomprehensible to a Shakespeare
because you couldn't have made the
wheels so so you know that way so much
of our physical world has changed that
that's got to be you know force number
or force number one at the same time I
think we've reached this very scary
point of questions of the limits of that
I mean it's clear that the biosphere
can't take a lot more and we may you
know we may have plenty of fossil fuel
left i'm not going to get into the peak
oil argument i don't know the answer to
that but we can't afford to burden and
and so we've reached i think a point
where we have got to change something if
we're going to continue that other arc
which I've you know I think we want to
do I mean it's been it's for the most
part it's been good for the common mass
of humanities and nostalgic people who
think gee wouldn't it be nice to live in
Lizbeth in' in Elizabethan times
probably wouldn't like the lice and the
body odor and the early death and the
small pox scars and all of those other
things in there you know the streets
full of and pee and horse and
human Nate I mean they probably wouldn't
like that world as much as they like it
depicted in cate blanchett movies so we
so I think we want to keep that and I
think we have some some real problems so
I think we're each of these other forces
the forces of anti-progress the forces
of non progress the forces of of what
you might call fundamental as nihilism I
mean they may believe in God but they
deny everything else is is these forces
seem to be very strong right now
worldwide in every religion you can
think of and
and and in every society you can think
of and getting getting through this
transition in the biosphere any and our
and in the the sphere in our heads is
going to be a pretty interesting
challenge